[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a América este es el
magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
156 millones de brasileños están
llamados a las urnas este domingo para
elegir presidente el actual mandatario
el ultraderechista Yair bolsonaro se
enfrenta al izquierdista de expresidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva les
explicamos los retos del próximo
mandatario
pero los brasileños también renuevan un
tercio del senado y eligen 513 diputados
y 27 gobernadores en medio de la
polarización entre izquierda y derecha
estos comicios son los que mayor
cantidad de candidatos diversos tienen y
nuestros corresponsales hablaron con
algunos de ellos y nos quedamos en
Sudamérica para hablar de Colombia y de
Venezuela el paso de dos camiones sobre
el puente internacional Simón Bolívar
selló la reapertura de la frontera entre
ambos países un paso del presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro para superar la
ruptura en los vínculos diplomáticos
y vamos de inmediato a Brasil para
nuestra historia principal son 11 los
aspirantes a la presidencia pero la
contienda es claramente un cara a cara
entre el actual presidente de
ultraderecha Yair bolsonaro y el ex
presidente de izquierda Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva bolsonaro un escéptico de
la pandemia y quien a menudo se le llama
el Trump sudamericano acusada Lula de
haber liderado del gobierno más corrupto
de la historia del Brasil Lula dejó el
cargo en 2010 con una tasa de aprobación
del 80%. esto antes de ser encarcelado
por corrupción una condena que luego
anuló la Corte Suprema el ex mandatario
acusa a bolsonaro de destruir el país
quien sea que se juramente como el
próximo presidente en enero enfrentará
los mismos retos que les explicamos en
el siguiente informe
dos hombres con visiones diametralmente
diferentes para su país el izquierdista
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva salió del
Palacio de plan alto en 2010 como el
presidente más popular de la historia de
Brasil Aunque su reputación se vio
manchada después por acusaciones de
corrupción sigue siendo recordado como
el líder que sacó a millones de personas
de la pobreza Brasil enfrenta niveles de
hambruna no vistos en 30 años por lo que
Lula está prometiendo llevar al país de
regreso a ese periodo un país
que la gente un país con trabajo un país
donde la gente tenía derecho a vivir con
dignidad con la cabeza en alto y este
país volverá
Lula ha prometido reformar el sistema
tributario para poner la carga
impositiva sobre los más ricos y obtener
un mayor presupuesto Estatal políticas
económicas que son Exactamente lo
contrario de las del actual mandatario
Yair bolsonaro que apoya una plataforma
neoliberal de mayor privatización y se
negó a cerrar la economía de Brasil
durante la pandemia del coronavirus lo
que provocó millones de miles de muertes
bolsonaro ha tratado de ganarse a los
votantes de escasos recursos Con dinero
en efectivo mientras pinta a Lula como
un comunista corrupto;
sabemos que el comunismo conduce a la
desgracia la pobreza el hambre y la
miseria no queremos eso para nuestro
Brasil Aunque
Los Seguidores del líder de extrema
derecha son en su mayoría fanático
religiosos Defensores del porte de armas
así como de la industria agrícola los
agricultores aprecian su eliminación de
la protección de los territorios
indígenas mientras que los evangélicos
se sientan atraídos por su Campaña
centrada en la defensa de la familia
tradicional bolsonaro a estado sembrando
dudas sin fundamentos sobre el sistema
de votación electrónico de Brasil lo que
genera temores de que se negaría a
aceptar la derrota sus críticos ahora
dicen que la democracia está en juego
debemos trabajar para ganar el voto de
todos los que aman la democracia
bolsonaru Un capitán retirado del
ejército buscó el respaldo de los
militares para sus afirmaciones
infundadas de fraude electoral e instó a
sus seguidores a armarse desde que
relajó las leyes de arma de fuego de
Brasil en 2019 la posición de armas se
ha disparado
contra esa cuadrícula tenemos que luchar
contra La Pandilla de Lula lucharemos y
repito el pueblo armado jamás será
esclavizado
la violencia política no es nueva en
Brasil el propio bolsonaro fue apuñalado
en la campaña electoral de 2018 pero
esta campaña ha estado marcada por
incidentes violentos con varios
simpatizantes de Lula heridos y un
funcionario asesinado por simpatizantes
de bolsonaro los mismos candidatos han
estado usando chalecos antibalas en
público según una encuesta reciente casi
el 70% de los brasileños dicen que temen
ser agredidos físicamente debido a su
afiliación política
y también en esta jornada de los
brasileños votan para elegir senadores
congresistas y gobernadores y por
primera vez se postularon más candidatos
afrodescendientes e indígenas que
blancos Asimismo más candidatos lgbtiq
más pero a pesar de la mayor diversidad
está es también la elección más
polarizada de Brasil en décadas y los
aspirantes temen más que nunca violencia
en su contra veamos el informe de
nuestros corresponsales
todos los lunes los jóvenes de Río de
Janeiro se reúnen empedradosal en el
centro de la ciudad un barrio cargado de
historias símbolo de la resistencia afro
brasileña un gran lugar para Dani balbi
una candidata a afro y transgénero que
busca apoyo
soy la primera mujer transgénero
profesora y doctora de la universidad
Federal de Río Dani quiere luchar por la
educación la comunidad lgbti con más los
derechos de los habitantes de las
favelas pero sobre todo por más
diversidad en las sillas del Congreso
por fin Alguien que nos porque los demás
candidatos hablan pero no hacen nada lo
vas a hacer porque te conozco y vas a
ser la mejor exactamente hermoso gracias
la primera vez que hay tantos candidatos
de la comunidad lgbtiq más en Brasil en
un país que tiene el
récord de asesinar a más personas
transgénero que en cualquier otro lugar
del mundo según la ong transgénero
Europa desde 2008 el 40% de los
asesinatos de personas trans en el mundo
han tenido lugar en Brasil
conoce a indianaraes yqueira también
candidata a diputada un activista
transgénero que ha recibido múltiples
amenazas de muerte sabes que todo
excusas las personas transgénero son las
primeras en ser rechazadas por la
sociedad en ser encarceladas Entonces
esta violencia ya es parte de nuestras
vidas siempre nos ha afectado pero en un
periodo como este adquiere proporciones
más intensas tuve que tomar precauciones
de seguridad y he estado en primera
línea durante años
esta violencia contra las minorías
incluso tiene lugar dentro de la
asamblea de Río hace unos meses este
diputado ultraderechista agredió a una
electa transgénero en plena sesión
parlamentaria
[Música]
según un estudio de la universidad
Federal del estado de Río la violencia
política aumentada en un
335% desde la elección del presidente
bolsonaro Hace cuatro años con políticos
que sufren agresiones verbales y físicas
secuestros e incluso asesinatos pero a
pesar del peligro nunca ha habido tantos
candidatos buscando representar a las
minorías entre ellos se encuentra Sonia
guajajara una mujer indígena que se
postula para diputada federal durante un
acto de campaña en Sao Paulo defiende
los derechos de los pueblos indígenas
que según Afirma han sido violados bajo
el gobierno de bolsonaro
estamos viviendo un genocidio de los
pueblos indígenas porque la negación de
nuestras tierras también es una
sentencia de muerte para nuestra
identidad
es hora de acabar con esta violencia es
hora de acabar con la falta de
representación indígena en los espacios
políticos Paz este año el número de
candidatos indígenas ha alcanzado un
récord 37% más que la última campaña la
ilusión de Sonia Guadalajara un grupo
parlamentario para que por fin su pueblo
tenga una representación fuerte y
Colombia le abrió la puerta nuevamente
al comercio con Venezuela y con el paso
de dos camiones sobre el puente
internacional Simón Bolívar que une la
ciudad colombiana de Cúcuta con la
venezolana de San Antonio del táchira
dieron un primer paso hacia la
normalización de sus relaciones
diplomáticas y comerciales el 26 de
septiembre ambos países reabrieron el
paso al transporte de carga después de
años de relaciones congeladas
un equipo de France 24 se trasladó hasta
la frontera entre ambas naciones para
conocer qué expectativas tienen sus
habitantes sobre esta nueva etapa en la
relación bilateral el informe es de
Daniela Blandón herminia Fernández y
aitor chavarry
[Música]
a sus clientes no lo tienen que buscar
él sale a su encuentro en la multitud
desde esta caótica frontera que une a
Colombia y Venezuela
el cierre de este paso en 2015 significó
para muchos la quiebra pero este
caraqueño jubilado de la Universidad de
Venezuela ayudó en él una oportunidad
que le ha dado sustento en los últimos
años con la misma necesidad la persona
de transportarse de de san antonio acá y
de aquí a San
Antonio de la parada y de la parada de
San Antonio porque eso porque no había
manera había que pasar bien por lo menos
él es una persona que no difícil que
cruza el puente
el gobierno venezolano de Nicolás maduro
y el colombiano del entrante Gustavo
Petro también de izquierda acordaron una
normalización de relaciones en una
primera etapa incluyó la reapertura del
paso de carga para Óscar Este primer
paso ya hace la diferencia mi patria lo
necesita
No importa que el trabajo se pueda
acabar por aquí por la frontera
pero no no antes necesitamos que
que esa economía de Venezuela se oxigene
un poquito por el momento la medida no
incluye el tránsito de carros
particulares ni de transporte
intermunicipal
y personas como él algunos cargados con
enormes bultos deben seguir Cruzando el
puente internacional Simón Bolívar a pie
y con horarios restringidos nada
Bienvenido a Venezuela
pero lo que para uno es una luz de
Esperanza otros lo ven con un optimismo
discreto Olga Muñoz administra una
empresa de transporte en el lado
colombiano de la frontera de aquí a
Pamplona y de Pamplona hasta ipiales yo
soy una mujer de 57 años que desde los
23 años estoy trabajando antes desde los
17 años trabajo y vivo en Venezuela yo
soy una inmigrante más salí de última
pero o sea Nos tocó salir por la
situación Confía en que el panorama
podría ser distinto pero en el fondo lo
que Espera es un cambio político en
Venezuela que el gobierno
se termine de irse vaya con la verdad de
otra manera no me parece que fue un como
algo de protocolo que pasó el camión con
los cables del acero y ya de repente me
va a mejorar en el sentido de que va a
poder a mis hermanos venezolanos comprar
unas cositas acá pero está la guardia
nacional al otro lado cierto Y qué hace
la guardia nacional cuando usted lleva
un bultico de Mercado
aparte de que le sale más caro entonces
la guardia nacional va a querer que
usted pague impuesto de lo poquito que
usted está llevando
como Óscar y Olga otras 30.000 personas
cruzan a diario esta frontera invisible
otros miles lo hacen y es posible que
por un buen tiempo más por las rutas
ilegales hoy más vivas que nunca en una
frontera común que se extiende a lo
largo de 2.217 km
y nos quedamos del lado colombiano de la
frontera Pero nos venimos para Bogotá en
donde luego de que el congreso fuera
declarado como un espacio amistoso con
los animales el senador alirio Barrera
llegó con su caballo a la sede del
legislativo y aunque se creía que la
medida Sería para perros y gatos el
senador sorprendió al llegar con su
caballo blanco bautizado pasaporte al
que considera su mascota afirmó que se
trataba de un acto simbólico pero con un
mensaje claro su desacuerdo con prohibir
algunas prácticas en las que se usan
animales para trabajar y otras
actividades económicas gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvieron Jennifer Guevara y
Luis Fernando Montes pueden ver esta
emisión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web france24.com
[Música]